this is the 20 minute story of factories and
smoke can sweat and toil and the half million men
and women whose job happens to be electricity the
beautiful pictures on the screen now don't seem to
have much to do with our job of work do they where
are things went along like this until suddenly one
day not long ago the whole electrical industry
every worker in the country in fact was snapped
into high gear here at Westinghouse it worked
with two men on a Friday and come back to the
job on Monday to find that you needed a dozen
orders beware overalls or store suits we come
on the job six days a week to punch in and take
over from the night shift some of us draw a pay
for putting up backs into it others for the know
how it takes to run a precision machine others
for pushing pencils or for drawing boards and
figuring out the math others from eating around
polished tables in the executive department
and tangling with the headaches of running
a business at capacity but whatever we are big
shots are little shots or old timers of rookies
a technical man or executive men are muscle men
it's the same job it's all part of the day's work
all right now that you've met us take a look at
one of the places where we put in our time it's
big and it's efficient it took the engineers
more than a lifetime to design this right and
develop it so that the books are now calling
it the American art of mass production well it
works it's working harder than it ever worked in
all history and that brings me to the big point
the thing that lies beyond the job we do here
though most of us over here were still in bed
he rolled his tanks and guns and death machinery
into Poland good morning while we were still
asleep we suddenly owned the port full of wrecked
battleships at Pearl Harbor and it took 2,000
American flags to cover the dead you'll remember
and the lights of our cities went out too it was
the end of a thousand old ideas about how tough
and safe we were it was the end of a lot before us
workers it was the beginning the beginning of the
capacity strain we put on factories like these and
the capacity strain the factories put on millions
of us to work with our heads in our hands and now
let's get down to some of the jobs we do if a new
development involved with electricity comes along
of course we have a lot to do with it because
electricity is our business after working out a
group of the problems connected with fluorescent
lighting we've put them into production
the girls turned out to be fine at these
jobs by the way they know how to work
rapidly without getting too rough with the
materials we test every single one of them
before their shift and this special device
makes it possible to handle dozens at the
same time we started out on these four
the idea that they'd go on the phones
and stores as well as factories we had to
change our plans couldn't wear these have
been life savers to the Black Dog factories
that had to find better artificial lighting
and speaking of light these big jobs would have
turn electricity into light and shoot at 10 of
15 miles into the sky we didn't have any wrong
notions about what these babies would have be
used for but after first nobody dreamed how many
we were going to have to turn out before we were
through and were not through yet you never can
tell we're following the trail of electricity
will lead you we've been turning out x-ray tubes
and parts for years among the very best in a
doctor could buy when suddenly orders came in
for x-ray machines that could be carried around
one that were portable to be taken right out
on battlefields and so of course that became
part of our day's work to then binoculars
not one person out of a hundred probably in
this country to guess that one of the greatest
electrical companies is making field glasses
but we have the men and women who knew how to
do fine delicate work and we had the machines
for it so here we are turning out binoculars
by the thousand so as part of our day's work
this is how we make and assemble the parts
of the precipitant and that's something we
like to pat ourselves in the back for a little
because we believe it's going to be one of the
enormous ly important improvements in the
American standard of life and because of
course this happened to be invented in Pittsburg
up in the research department this machine draws
the dust and oil particles and pollen out of
the air while you're asleep or awake and it
was planned for peacetime homes and factories
that is until the Nazis and Japs forced us to
discover a thousand wartime uses for it and
this insecticide dispenser is another one of
those things way outside of our main job of
electricity scientists discovered that one
of the gases used in refrigerators would work
into a mixture safe for humans but that would
put bugs and mosquitoes out of commission for
good so part of the day's work now is to turn
out an endless number of these and we send
them down to where malaria carries death to
our boys and they do save many a man's life you
know it gives you a peculiar feeling to realize
with nearly every job that comes under your hands
nowadays is mixed up with life and death but I'll
explain that a little later because here come
the places where we spend so much of our time
you are in you're living in the shadow of the
stacks in the sound of crashing metal presses
are in the glare of the arc welder and here we
are part of the hundred thousand men and women of
Westinghouse literally piled up on the executives
desks the call for more and more workers went
ringing out all over the land day in and day
out training classes meant and men and women are
boys and girls who've never had grease under their
fingernails in their lives now learn what it would
mean to run a machine you used to know everybody
who worked in your department now the new faces
showed up every day sometimes we had to teach the
rookies in a few weeks but we've been months or
years in learning and you should see the way the
girls make good on these jobs to the executive
employees met hour after hour over problems beyond
anything that ever encountered because from the
office point of a boss the pressure was on for now
it becomes clear but at that time in Washington
and London the leaders were planning that little
surprise party for Hitler and all hell was gonna
break loose in Africa of course we didn't exactly
know this but that was what added so heavily to
our world and now we know that a part of the
laughing and the victory in Africa was born
right in our plants right under our own hands and
now another thing becomes clearer to why the whole
electrical industry tooled up and prepared so long
before Pearl Harbor it's management's job to look
into the future and what they must have seen in
the future looked like a lot more work for all of
us because they began to prepare long in advance
at the heart of every need in the nation would
lie the electrical industry that was the great
fact of the pre-war months our labor-management
committees saw the handwriting on the wall which
our industry had been carrying on for years this
was research take the Ignite room here for example
this development converts alternating current into
direct current in enormous quantities we'd worked
on this so long that when the crisis came we were
all ready to supply them in quantity to industries
everywhere then when the enormous demand for more
aluminum hit everybody between the eyes the
public learned that every pound of it had to
be produced by electricity by direct current so
that aluminium goes out in ever-increasing amounts
today headed for airplanes mostly because in
part the Ignatian we developed through the years
was ready for the job the research department
sometimes seems like a lot of blue sky dreaming
to the man of works of his hands but this war has
proved its value over and over a thousand times
this special device for finding out the hidden
weaknesses inside metal and plastics it might
just look like a clever toy until you learn that
because of this manufacturers all over the world
are going to redesign parts and they say that
even railroad tracks will be made differently
in the future because we're discovering what
it is that wears them out yes the research men
spend a lot of time peering into the future
it was long ago when Westinghouse began to
put the alternating current motor over but we're
using him now and in quantities the boys over in
Germany can't hope to match this steam turbine
- it was developed out of thousands of hours of
research and today with every industry crying
for more power the whole country knows that
it's a good thing to have around a man could go
on about research for months it's a big subject
but I'll close this with one of the latest times
research into the ideas of the thousands of us
will have the practical jobs the college boys have
no monopoly on brains said the bosses and this was
the result and many a job is growing faster and
easier and more efficiently because of a slip
of paper dropped into this box all this then was
our way of being prepared for the biggest day's
work that ever hit American industry the juice is
still turned on full and we know now that the job
we did to help in Africa and Sicily is just a
taste of the chore that lies ahead now so here
we come to the merchandise we're fixing up for
Hitler and Tojo right this minute you should see
the size of the turbines would make an assemble
now even George Westinghouse where he's still
alive today might gasp at them and the gears too
complicated as a Chinese puzzle yet actors as a
watch but it's all in the day's work now nice job
don't you think and deep in their insides are the
things we made with our brains and our hands
these giant transformers - they confused the
visitor but the Navy loves him no fighting ship
could go down to sea without them they transform
the energy of the generators into fighting power
and lest I overlook the most generally used most
important piece of equipment of them all gears
the familiar electric motor without it that just
wouldn't be in American industry and no mechanized
warfare life would go back a hundred years every
electrical company makes them now from tiny jobs
you could hold in your hand to those that rise
up before your big as a six room house and the
girls nowadays instead of making dainty little
garments they're making neat little bomb fuses
we improved upon the standard specifications for
this job we made it better than the military
even asked and we made it for less money
just in the day's work and yet it's a package full
of hell for the anime with love
and kisses for the worker demands
and they said if we could make generators
big enough for Grand Coulee Dam we ought to
be able to turn out a gun big enough for this
war and here she is and this is from us heal to
Schicklgruber Montoya and the monks for the guns
don't look Saudis gun mounts apart in the Nazi
laboratories now trying to turn out imitations
but there still is full of military secrets is
the Casablanca conference because we build
electric brains into them and send them over
there with our compliments to the men behind
and here's another part of our day's work it
pulls the visitors because it looks so peaceful
but we know that the blood stream of a bombing
plane is electricity and the thing that pumps
it must be a generator that's lighting weight
we scale pound after pound off the weight of this
one so that in place of the weight the old type
electric generators took the Flying Fortresses
can load more gasoline and more bombs it doesn't
show does it looking way up there the work we
did but it's there and it's a part of history
radial equipment of course is right down
our alley and night and day around the
clock we bend over the work and
make the perfect parts it takes
it has to be made right of course because every
detail may mean that some boy whom we will never
see will owe his life to the equipment we
made even making the instruments that glow
on the panel before the pilot is all a part
of our day's work and because they have to be
hairline accurate the girls laborious ly turn
each one out by hand need work don't you think
knate work to lie before a brave man's eyes and
telling me to glance the story of his airplane
and take these helmets that we're making by
the hundred so it gives you an idea of why the
electrical industry is so big and complicated
that no one man can completely understand it
all our research worked out of plastic years
ago and here it is now forming shields around
the heads of every man of bases combat /
this goes his steel helmet the single most
precious possession a soldier ever has we'll
never meet these boys we millions will work
for them but that's all I that plastic helmet
liner is a part of us dude this is the last one
will show the test for a torpedo tube a torpedo
costs about as much as a fine automobile and it
has cost the Japs many a ship but because
in our industry you've got to know you've
made things right they first see action like this
and the last time they see action it's like this
death in every one of them here is electricity
the Unleashed power of sixty six thousand volts
electricity to work for man in peace or in war
electricity death to the enemies of freedom and
that's what we mean by the hundred thousand of
us and our day's work then one day you remember
the officials came in from Washington to give us
the Army and Navy e and the executives marched in
smiling and thousands of us got into this movie at
last yet while they were making their speeches you
could look up and see the flag familiar as these
awards have become and it really meant something
to you you know or somebody probably put in
a day's work sewing that flag together and
somebody else probably made this one to all in his
day's work although I understand that more than a
million men have made it their day's work to die
for it at one time or another it means something
and there's two the executives planning it the
engineers and designers and architects putting
it down on paper and the mechanics and painters
and carpenters putting it up against the sky it
was just in the day's work but it meant something
this was a job too that meant something somebody
got paid for building this and he was glad
to get paid but it meant something more to it
and that's part of how we feel about it we do
our day's work and we get paid so that we can
look after our families and take it easy
now and then and give the kids something
that's it kids give them a good education
in a free country where a man can shoot off
his mouth and speak his mind without going to
jail for it it's all in the day's work but it
means something and this after all is what it
means and that's the story of the millions of
us Americans who work with our brains and our
hands in the day's work that spells victory